we know you've been waiting a long time
and now we finally are here Kendall
Jenner is finally addressing her recent
Photoshop Photoshop fail uh some people
say but not without a helping hand oh
from her pal Haley paper okay I like
what you did there I give it a six out
of ten if you haven't been keeping up
that's definitely an eight out of ten it
all started over the weekend when
Kendall posted a photo of herself
spending time on the beach but but but
fans couldn't help but notice her hands
uh appeared to be photoshopped with some
users pointing out her fingers just look
way too long y'all okay yes well Haley
Bieber came to her friend's defense and
jokingly posted a video of Kendall's
hands to prove once and for all that she
just has long hands take a look sitting
here analyzing look bizarre her hand for
him normally
live live footage of the hands
she has long alien fingers I mean I'm
not gonna lie when I first saw the photo
and I was like sorry what's everyone
talking about she looks like she's
crunched over in pain because she's on
vacation ate too much cheese it's a lot
going on there like I want to make sure
she's cool but you can see the
discoloration you know by the hand and
the legs right so if we're gonna break
if we're gonna break this photo
okay so we're talking about the length
of finger I'm gonna block this right now
did you just want to get closer to the
photo length of finger to uh wrist ratio
I believe is what we're talking about
now some people might be pointing out
the fact that like you said
discoloration there's sand all around
this is true this is Sandy yeah this
little bit there Sandy so I'm saying I
don't know the first time I saw the
picture too I was like whoa Avatar yeah
like whey water I was like Navi but
uh now that you know you bring it up
that her hand and that video could be
proof that's interesting weird angle I
agree listen I think people are
sensitive the Kardashians haven't called
out before for photoshopping some of
their photos whether it's true or not uh
yeah I don't think that's the case in
this situation do you think it's more
people were like you just want an excuse
to talk about this particular photo I
mean it's quite the photo quite the
photo you know there's there's
nobody wants to talk about a picture of
me like that that's I don't that would
be right I also wouldn't nobody wants
that out there yeah myself I was looking
at your hands I was looking to see how
now your hands are they're fine how
Nobby are my hands they're no right like
who has the more Navi hands I think
maybe I do equal I think yeah I don't
know I have like I have like sausage
fingers
see that's the thing so she like you
know
have you cracked the case I feel like
Haley Haley Bieber did so thank you yeah